foreign
I'll make an effort to stay on on
schedule a big thanks to the organizers
for having me I've had a blast so far in
part because as thought said you know we
get to meet people that we haven't seen
in a while but also I think you know
I'm against anything Zoom based these
days you know in-person meetings are the
right way to go to talk and chat and
argue
um so my talk is on decision making with
information therapy constraints that's
kind of my take on you know machine
learning with information Theory it
actually does connect quite well to
quite a few things that we've heard
about over the last few days so I'm
going to connect to a Tara presented on
on day one I'm gonna kind of piggyback
on some of the comments Aaron made about
um you know living Distortion Theory
aside on classical Distortion Theory
aside for a little bit and I'm going to
talk about sure enough information like
we heard from the previous talk uh you
know I should first and foremost start
by giving credit where it's due
um so I've had really good students
who've actually helped me if not done
most of the work around these topics and
so I won't go into the details but they
deserve a lot of credit and you know
congrats on your newborn I also have a
little one now
baby was born five days before the
lockdown
and he's doing rkhs doing office hours
to teach grad students what to do
um all right uh my second slide about
you know credit where it's due a lot of
what we've explored in that space is
very much motivated after I read uh two
really cool papers well technically
three I mean so the sequential design of
experiment paper
um by by turn off but also like more
modern takes on that from maybe 10 years
ago now so there's a nice paper on
control sensing for multi-hypertensive
testing coming from the corn fields
um
and and Tara you know kind of had a
similar take on that Collective
sequential hypothesis testing and these
things are kind of generalization of the
the sequential paper of turn off and
when I read them you know it's kind of
interesting that the connect actually
control and machine learning and
information theory in a nice way and so
I got kind of fascinated by these
results and you know very briefly and
not giving doing full Justice to
everything people have done the problem
is the following so imagine you know you
have a kernel here that generates
you know samples that you can observe
and then your goal is to make a decision
about the hidden parameter that governs
that distribution
so the controlled sensing or actually I
put existing view of this says well you
know there's also another input which
we're going to call you that allows you
to tweak that kernel so you can actually
take actions and these actions can
actually be dependent on your past
observations you can close the loop and
adapt how you're going to probe to get
samples and the goal is to get an
estimate of theta that is as reliable as
possible as fast as possible
there are lots of variations of that
setup but you can say I want to get
exactly n samples that's called the
fixed length setting
um and that's kind of I think the
easiest one to connect to from an
information Theory perspective because
we're used to having like a fixed
blocklings but the best things you get
are when you start allowing
sequentiality meaning you have a
stopping time you have a rule to decide
when you stop probing and then you
replace your block length n by an
expected stopping time for instance
um and then you can ask questions you
know does it benefit me to be sequential
versus fixed blocklines you can also say
does it benefit me to actually adapt my
probing as I get my observations
um but generally speaking the key
quantity that people look at and I'm
oversimplifying a little bit here is
this notion that if you have a fixed set
of hypotheses let's say Theta takes one
of n parameters you can look at the air
exponent when you make a decision on
Theta and you can measure the quality
um by taking the limit as NATO plus
black length of the log of the
probability of making an error with a
fixed policy Pi here divided by n so
it's kind of quantifying the error
exponent how fast you make that decision
so if Theta is not taking values from a
finite set you know it takes a Continuum
of values you have to enter the the
realm of you know crime around bounds
and whatnot so I'm not going to talk
about that today
and um what motivated me with that is
that this is actually a pretty powerful
model that abstracts a lot of the
problems we have with dealing with
feedback and how to make decisions once
we have bus observations I know you're
not quite as sophisticated as what Todd
was presenting this morning but you know
some of what was presenting is the
flavors are in these models
and and the mission for me was to say
okay I mean there are lots of problems
in engineering where this model actually
has a lot of things to say still and so
I'm going to kind of give you two
vignettes of things we've thought about
so one was motivated by a really cool
paper that's actually coming from the
quantum world where people were going
from an IC actually I think
um where people were saying they've
invented a covered radar right so you
want to illuminate a plane that's coming
but you don't want the plane to realize
it's being illuminated right because
that's one of those things you know like
if you watch military movies right like
the planes get accumulated they start
evading and whatnot that's when movies
gets interesting but what if they can't
detect right they're being illuminated
so they call that the covered radar and
I thought you know that model might be a
cool way to think about you know
discovered radar but then you need to
Define you know what does it mean to be
covered and so we're going to modify the
problem a little bit and I'll say more
in a few slides where you know you have
to kind of look at it in two ways
there's a
well potentially there's a there's a
closed loop which you control that's a
person operating the radar but then
there's an adversary who is being
illuminated and they also have to check
you know is something happening am I
being illuminated so you're trying to
make a best decision but there's a
constraint implicit about you know what
you can do to Pro because if you probe
to how you're going to be detected so we
can formulate kind of interesting games
here so I'll talk about that and the
second scenario I would illustrate is
one that's becoming popular with all the
folks doing 6G you know I don't know
what 6G is going to be it's going to be
a more expensive cell phone that I can
guarantee you that but uh they're
talking about you know
convergence of different frequency bands
you can do communication and radar at
the same time and so if you think about
that it's kind of uh you know if you
believe that you know my radar is a
hypothesis testing problem I'm trying to
probe to figure out the value of a
parameter now the constraint that you
have is that the probe they also have to
embed information and so you know
biomodification of this canonical active
hypothesis testing problem you can try
to embed this sort of reliability
information to a deep construct so I'm
going to try to highlight that I kind of
highlight I think what also the kind of
the key technical challenges that one
has to play with
um but I won't go into a whole lot of
details so let me start with the active
covered sensing so the active coverage
sensing the way we formulated it in its
simplest form is the you know again the
following diagram so we have this closed
loop that's a hectic like what is this
testing problem where you're trying to
estimate the parameter Theta the kicking
a finite number of values by probing and
possibly adapting your strategy
um but now we're going to introduce a
second output to the kernel that gives
you the samples so the kernel also is a
function of theta uh you know the action
in production U but then there's an
output Z that goes to what we call the
detector it's the adversial detector so
think of it as it's a plane so you're
trying to illuminate a Target to see if
you know there's a plane or not so Teta
tells you you know if there's a plane or
not what kind of plane and then zi is
the plane itself right it has a detector
okay I'm being illuminated and um
so you know one thing that's important
to note is that our adversary is open
okay so the adversary doesn't have any
any uh input on the feedback link right
so as the radar we get to adjust what we
do but the adversary fundamentally is at
a disadvantage uh because it is uh it
doesn't have controllable feedback
to make the problem interesting so in
our case we want to model something we
call Active covered something
um we need to to Define what it means to
be covered okay and so that's kind of
what I want to highlight the are these
kind of cute maybe Niche information
theoretic Notions but they kind of
capture some cool problems so to be
covered it means you need to Define what
it means to not be detected and so we
have to assume that there is one action
and I'm going to call it zero for
Simplicity that's my reference action
which means I'm not doing anything so if
you have a radar it means you're not
probing
without sending energy into your Channel
um and then you also need to explain
that you know if you don't do anything
there's nothing useful that comes out of
it
so we also have to assume that if you
don't probe you can't distinguish the
different parameters okay so I have to
be explicit about these assumptions
because if you give me a system or by
doing nothing you know I'm getting
different samples or different
distributions different data then cost
me nothing to estimate right so this
assumptions they are important to state
but they mean something physical like
from an engineering perspective
and we're also going to assume that the
adversary is actually quite powerful it
knows that are so it knows the state of
the channel I mean the plane knows
whether it's here or not and it knows
the strategy that's being used by by the
radar right so if the radar decides to
do something smart and adaptive this
detector knows what's going on
and so how do you measure the ability of
a detector to to to detect if you're
doing something or not to the input well
you need to frame that as a binary
hypothesis testing problem I put the
null hypothesis you know this early
simple Alice the transmitter does
nothing sends Zero versus Alice does
something smart with the strategy
so here's the kind of thing that we can
characterize and I want to mostly
highlight you know what what standard
and what's maybe not standard and what's
intriguing to us so I'm going to look at
non-adaptive strategies we have more
results but uh for Simplicity I'll just
focus on the framing here for the
simplest case
um
so we're interested in characterizing
the error exponents right and we're
going to look at the worst case okay so
what is over all possible hypothesis
that I'm trying to discriminate form
what is the worst probability of error I
can get and I'm going to try to look at
something that looks like an AR exponent
and I think what what the Intriguing
thing in some of you are still following
is that I'm not normalizing by n I'm
normalizing by square root of N and I
think that's one key signature of my
covertness constraint and I'm going to
articulate why it's there is that you
can't normalize by any cameras by n you
get zero essentially it's telling you
that if you want a positive error
exponent in the traditional sense of
um
oops nor normalizing by n uh you get
zero because the governance constraint
essentially says well it should not be
detected so you really can do much
but it turns out that they can do much
means you have to use square root of n
and the second part here is my
covertness constraint actually which I'm
going to explain a few more details I'm
going to require that when I have used
my strategy worst case ever all possible
hypothesis I try to discriminate from I
want the relative entropy between the
Distribution on the
output disease that the detector sees
um and a distribution that is induced
when I don't do anything okay so when I
write pz given Theta of zero it's a
distribution induced when I only send
zero at the input of my channel so this
is my reference doing nothing Behavior
and this Pia with a bold phase Z here is
the one that is induced by me using a
strategy and I want that to be less than
10. okay so I'll come back to the result
you know we actually have an exact
characterization of the optimal exponent
uh for non-adaptive strategies in that
case I want to talk about this because I
think that I want to convince you of
anything is that this is a fun
constraint to work with
so why why do I claim that this relative
entropy constraint actually is something
that you can view as a common test
constraint well both actually from from
very simple results so if you have any
test T of Z that you conduct on the
sequence of observation Z that you
obtained
there's a pretty
standard result that says that there's a
trade-off between probability of false
alarm and misdetection that takes the
following form priority or False Alarm
Plus probability of misdetection has to
be greater than one minus the total
variation one have uh sorry one half the
norm one between the distribution that
you expect when somebody is probing and
the distribution when somebody is not
probing and using pin switch inequality
you can relate that to a relative entry
so when I say I want this to be small it
means I want this to be close to one
okay so operationally and graphically
what does that mean so let me use this
curve here because as you can see here
if I use relative entropy there is a
Pinter inequality that's hiding
somewhere so there's some looseness
there so let's forget that for a second
let's focus on using this metric here
and see what it means in terms of an RC
curve so you're plotting traditionally
when you want to assess the performance
of hypothesis test you look at
probability of detections one minus
productive mean detection versus
probability of false alarm and any test
has a trade-off curve in the plane and
it's actually in the upper left quadrant
or above the diagonal it's not you can
always find another test immediately
that has a property
so when we say that Alpha plus beta so
really probability of new detection
possibility of function should be close
to one what do we mean we mean that the
RSC curve should be close to that
diagonal why does that ensure you know
undetectability but think about what's
happening on the diagonal especially the
points 0 0 at the bottom it means
probability of false alarm is zero
probability of misdetection is one
right so how do you design a detector
like that
it's it's a you know fire alarm that
actually never triggers
okay so you never have a false alarm but
you never detect anything so this is
kind of pointless you know if your
detector has that performance it's not
doing anything and similarly the upper
right corner probability of Mis
detection is zero productive false alarm
is one that's a fire alarm that's always
ringing so you're not getting anything
and in between the diagonal is just an
interpolation you know probabilistic by
flipping a coin between these two modes
so any detector that has an Roc curve
that is on that diagonal means it's not
doing anything
um statistically significant and so if
we constrain any Roc curve to have an
RSC curve that is kind of squeezed close
to one this is what we call coveredness
because you can do something very
sophisticated but it's not statistically
relatable somebody can just do some
random guesses and we'll get the exact
same statistical performance so that's
coverless
so when we use this relative entropy as
opposed to a norm one
we introduced some slack if you want a
relative entropy that's less than Delta
you're actually not controlling as
finely The ROC curve
um it won't matter for this talk but I
just want to mention that we're using
this because it's simpler to manipulate
if you want to manipulate this there's a
bit more work that's involved but this
is actually the right quantity like if
you want like a tight notion of
coveredness you should use this and not
that but that's so now
why so all that even said there is that
weird square root of n that showed up in
my result right so why is there a square
root of n
so think about what we're trying to say
here we're trying to say that you're you
you're forcing a statistical test
on you know you know what people are
doing the probing and yet you should not
be able to distinguish what they're
doing from them doing nothing
so implicitly what that means is that
whatever disturbance they include at the
input of the Channel with their probing
strategy
should somehow introduce a disturbance
at the output that is statistically not
detectable
and if you think about any test that you
can run on a sequence of length n think
about you know you're measuring the
power let's say you know you can always
form a very simple empirical estimation
of the average power and then you say
well okay that's just an average you
know how good is my estimator you look
at the variance and the third deviation
is one over square root of n so
essentially this intuition tells you
that whatever disturbance you introduce
you will have to make sure that that
disturbance stays within the statistical
noise and the statical noise has the
square root of n that shows up so that's
really why there's a square root of 10
is because the amount of disturbance you
can introduce has to be negligible
compared to the power of the statistical
uh estimator that you get
so that's kind of um so we've been
playing a lot of business in many
different situations but what it does is
it creates this situation where you have
to normalize differently and you have to
look at all the qualities that you're
used to analyzing In This Very extreme
regime where you don't do much right so
for instance if you were to do not just
you know covered probing but covered
communication you have to hide square
root of and bits of information in a
sequence of length n and then it's you
know it's not that easy to I mean we
know how to do it but you know you have
to convince yourself that you have this
very diffused information content and
yet you can retrieve it right so here
there is that same flavor you have this
very diffused probing
you have this diffuse probing and yet
you know it's still useful for you to
get something and the answer is yeah
it's still useful but you take a huge
penalty like your probability of air is
going to Decay like exponential minus
something times square root of n as
opposed to n but we can say what exactly
is that error exponent beta in its type
so I want to highlight you know this is
the answer that we have uh it's a bit
unwieldy when you look at it I just want
to highlight that there's something cool
about it that's very intuitive so if you
know channel of information you
recognize that it's here that's a chair
of information
um okay technically the show of
information is this one here because we
have this
active you know we can choose the set of
actions that we use and even if we're
not adaptive we can sample use from a
fixed distribution so potentially you
can average your chain of information so
that's why there's a sum over you you're
averaging turn off information for a
given input but that's just the
signature of our ability to control the
channel input okay so that's your turn
of information so that's to be expected
um what's interesting is that you have
that term here so that term here is the
signature of the covertness constraint
so I'll explain a second why you have a
chi-square metric
um it has to do with the fact that the
chi-square is essentially this when you
do a Taylor extension so you can disturb
too much so if you look at the Taylor
like a first
Taylor expansion of relative entropy
when you just say okay my this cannot be
too much different from that so it's a
disturbance of this was a little
something a little something will tell
you that it's then multiplied by the
first order in your Taylor series which
is a chi-square that's what it's coming
from and the good the other real thing
is that Delta so Delta shows up here
so that's maybe another surprising thing
I wanted to point out in traditional
information theoretic problems usually
we have these strong Converse results
like they tell you you know it doesn't
matter whether you want Delta or Delta
to be very small or you know like that
if you normally like the fundamental
limits that we're after they don't
depend on these Epsilon Deltas but here
it does depend on jobs
and and I think that's also kind of fun
signature of this covertness problem is
that we're imposing constraints to go
back to my problem here we're inputting
constraints on not really the
information embedding we're imposing a
constraint on the shape of the signal
and that's actually a much more
stringent constraint
and so that usually there's no strong
Converse in that case you know if you if
you want your relative entropy
you know between the distribution you
induce and your reference to Belize and
Delta and Delta is two or Delta is 0.2
or 0.02 is going to change how much you
can do all right so it's it's in a way
it's both more I mean it's a more
fragile result if you wish so you have
to set a predefined Delta and you know
how big your exponent or how small will
be will depend on that belt all right so
let me just highlight you know how we go
about proving this and it's both you
know not complicated and there are some
subtleties so we have to do two things
if you think about proving that we can
find a strategy because everything is
non-adaptive you actually don't have to
worry about closing the loop what you
have to worry about is deciding you know
like a sequence of actions you that
you're going to use in open loop okay
and so you still need to make sure you
can upper bound the coveredness so that
you guarantee coveredness and you you
know we want to kind of control the type
of the input
so
because you're covered
you can really not use a channel too
much okay so you need to find the right
fraction of Channel users where you
actually do something meaningful
and and that fraction as I argued before
it is like one over square root of x
that's kind of
then you need to show that you can
achieve that exponent
so it's the kind of the cool thing that
you have to do or cool I mean intriguing
things that are kind of tricks we like
to play with is if you try like an ID
strategy you're not going to get
anywhere and the reason this kind of
things don't work directly is because
you're operating in that weird regime or
you know the CLT kicks in right so you
have to make sure that whatever you do
it's not enough to control the mean of
your quantities you need to make sure
that you have a tight control of the
variance
and so the way we do that is we use kind
of a you know
intriguing information Theory you look
at certain sequences of a given type but
you need to Define you know what these
sequences are very precisely so if you
allow a fraction Alpha of non-zero
symbols you need to make sure that when
you define types they have to be within
some Alpha times this one constant of of
your reference distribution p and and
given when Alpha decreases so it kind of
forces you to analyze you know like all
your traditional type results very
careful and typically that involves
things a bit more sophisticated than
holding's inequality
I think the first time I talked about
this Max was in the audio and said yeah
of course use Bernstein's inequality
because it gives you control of the
variance as well so that's kind of
exactly the kind of tricks we have to
play with
okay so
um the the converse is where you really
get to understand you know why we have a
chi-square distance that shows up
um and um for the sake of time I'm gonna
go a bit fast but the way the converse
works you can't make any assumption
right so you have to start saying you
have a strategy that strategy you know
you can do a like empirical average
across time it defines the probability
that your strategy uses the symbol one
no sorry a non-zero symbol
um and then using traditional techniques
you can kind of get Converse bounds on
on the probability of error you can
lower bound them as a function of the
chain of information once you start
focusing on the time instance where
you're using a non-zero symbol remember
zero symbols don't give you any
information so essentially the Converse
that the first part is a bit trivial
you're just saying well let me write my
Converse taking into account that even
though I have n symbols effectively I
might use only a fraction one over
square root of the N of that so do you
get such balance but the second thing is
to realize okay you need to satisfy the
cover test constraint and again what
you're going to say is you're going to
take your relative entropy constraint do
a now that you know that you can only
use a non-zero symbol or fraction Alpha
of the time Alpha is very small you do
your Taylor series and this is nothing
this first term here is nothing but a
Taylor series of the relative entropy
between
um
this quantity here and your reference
and you immediately see that the alpha
Square goes out it's upper body by Delta
over answer Alpha your fraction of
Channel uses as to be behaving like
succin as a function of Delta but most
importantly behaving as like one over
square root of N and this turns out to
give us the optimal constant so we get
the exact characterization okay so that
was my first illustration of kind of you
know how you can use to do very
traditional results to talk about things
like covered radar
um and you know some folks at MIT have
built something like that it's Quantum
so it's more fancy but it's a spirit of
what they're doing
all right so how much time do I have
evidence okay so the second vignette I
wanted to highlight
um
which I think you know I got more
excited about it's more recent too but
um I think makes a better case for why
these uh models matter is is to apply
that in the context of what people now
called Joint communication and sensing
so just to you know pretend that it
matters for 6G okay this is my one PR
side
um
so I mean there's real stuff that's
happening like people are pushing
towards millimeter wave systems so um
very high frequencies it starts to you
know hit the frequencies where people
traditionally do radar and so you know
if you're an engineer you want to save
money save power it kind of makes sense
to have one Hardware that does two
things so why not use the same Hardware
to do joint communication and sensing
and if you believe in vehicular networks
you know then they can talk to each
other detect that they are you know
Targets in range so you know it's safer
because you don't hit pedestrians all
right so how do you talk about these
problems
exactly
yeah you know in Atlanta it matters
um
this is not my picture right so they
call it a Target
[Music]
yeah so you know be careful when you
create cartoonish
cartoonish description of the research
but that's not from me okay
um all right so how do we talk about
this in information Theory terms and so
I promise that we typed some of the
comments that Aaron made earlier about
you know the need to maybe start
thinking about beyond the traditional
rate Distortion problem and so I'm going
to make that case here so there are some
folks who've done some otherwise
extremely nice work but they've tried to
model this joint communication and
sensing problem
with an approach that has this flavor of
red Distortion and so the way they model
the problem is as follows so they're
saying you know you have a translator
here trying to transmit a message
through a channel
okay so that channel has uh you know one
part that goes to your receiver your
receiver has to get the message the
channel also depends on the state you
can call that s
and you have a feedback Channel possibly
noisy that you have to use to estimate
the state of the channel okay so when
you look at that model you know you have
feedback well close the loop all right
so feedback does not increase capacity
but you know it's a bit more subtle than
that um Aaron can attest to that you
know they are you know you so feedback
can be very useful
um so you will want to close the loop so
but we impose a constraint that we care
about decoding the message and
estimating the state now if your
information theory is what's very
natural to do is to say well you know my
State should be ID
okay now I'm going to argue quickly that
in the context of this joint
communication and sensing problem you
know whether you have a pedestrian or
not is not an ID
um but you know if you do that then it's
very natural to measure your performance
with two metrics one is the probability
of decoding air the other is an average
distortion
but this is great and it's great in part
because you can characterize the
trade-off between the rate of
communication and the Distortion D
exactly okay so um I'm not going to
elaborate too much on the specifics of
the the result I'm going to give you the
spirit of it and there are two great
papers I encourage you to look at if
you're interested
but essentially the gist of the result
is the following it says
um
there's really no need to close the loop
why because that state is ID keeps
changing so you're closing the loop
is not gonna at all improve their
ability to learn anything
the state keeps changing so in a way
closing the loop here is useless and
what you should do is you should
provision for a desired level of
trade-off that you're interested in
what's kind of cool is that you know
information Theory allows you to start
with these very high dimensional
problems we're coding over block blanks
and and then goes to Infinity but in the
end the the trade-off will characterizes
in terms of quantities that are single
lateralized they don't depend on N
anymore and the quantities of relevance
here end up depending on one quantity
only which is the type of the codeword
that you transmit their empirical
distribution or the histogram of their
their content and so that alone controls
the optimal trade-off between the
Distortion level that you have in your
stake reconstruction and the the the
rate that you can push to reliably
through the channel okay so by the way
uh I was at ITW a few weeks back and
they were focused on industry there we
talked about that and for them this is
not necessarily a bad thing okay I'm
going to start questioning that model
but for from an industry perspective you
should design a network the idea that
you have to provision for certain
trade-offs is very natural and from
their perspective what I'm going to
argue next which is this idea that oh no
you can do fine level adaptation they're
like oh no we don't want to do that okay
that sounds scary and complicated right
so what has to be careful the reason I I
don't certainly don't mean to trash this
result they're actually potentially very
relevant but what I'm going to argue
though is that this ID model that's
something that's really inspired from
Wireless you know if you're trying to
worry about a Target you know your
pedestrian or your person on the bike is
not going that fast okay certainly they
don't change at the rate of your symbol
rates in 6G and so it sort of makes
sense to take a step back and start to
think about the time scales over which
the state is evolving
and we're going to do it by the extreme
by saying s is not changing okay so
we're going to have fixed cellular State
what we're going to bring in is this
ability to now learn the state S as we
go
so in the interest of time um I'll keep
that quick but again a lot of folks have
done some cool extension of you know
this ID model but to us the motivation
was what's missing with a red Distortion
Theory approach is it's kind of an ad
hoc you know information theoretic
perspective on these problems but it's
kind of maybe missing the bigger point
which is what you're trying to detect
move slowly and so you don't need this
ID modeling assumption and the moment
you drop it then it gives you the
ability to adapt because you can learn
okay so on credit where it's due again
there's another group and Friends
Williams actually was involved that had
similar ideas at about the same time so
our results were very similar in some
sense okay
so what's the model that we're looking
at now so for us it's the same model
that I presented you before except the
channel state is fixed now okay so now
you can learn okay that's a big
difference we're going to assume that s
takes a finite amount finite number of
values so then the performance of your
estimation can be measured in terms of
the exponent of the probability of error
you try to do your estimation
okay so the encoder can use the feedback
the noisy feedback so there's a delay so
you don't have instantaneous feedback
and your decoder is trying to estimate
the message
so
in the grand scheme of things you could
ask for a very complicated trade-off you
could say I want to understand how fast
my probability of decoding error decays
versus how fast my probability of
estimation error of the state decays
versus how much rate I'm pushing through
the channel that's a three-dimensional
trade-off that's complicated
it's complicated because we already know
that the trade-off between the rates and
your the decay of your probability of
message decoding error it's linked right
the further you are away from capacity
if you take some slightly Decay faster
so we wanted to remove that
so we're just going to ask for the
trade-off between the rate of
communication and the probability of
detection error for the state
so we only care that the property of
decoding error is small but we're not
going to look at the exponential decay
that's for Simplicity
we have a trade-off between the rate R
and the detection error exponent
note that
because of the setup here where you have
a fixed number of channeled States
unless your kernel here gives you you
know no observation any strategy no
matter how silly will eventually allow
you to estimate s properly right so it's
important to look at the exponent to get
an interesting trade-off
all right that's what we want we want
trade-off between the rate of
communication are
subject to the constraint that you want
to kind of decode correctly so probably
if there are no more than Epsilon and
your exponent for the probability of
State detection is greater than e minus
Epsilon and we're on the trade-off
between R and E you know I've seen on a
smaller Z1
yeah so in terms of um
terminology
it's good to start with a strategy that
doesn't use the feedback it's usually
easier to analyze I'm going to call that
open loop if I start using the feedback
I'm going to call that close loop and
and we want the trade-off
so in open loop things are nice because
we get an exact characterization we want
to speed back not too surprising and
again we get this idea that the result
takes that following form so the rate
region that tells you the trade-off
between the rate of communication and
the exponents of your detection is a
trade-off between the array that's
upbounded by sort of the compound
capacity type
and the exponent is that for complicated
function Phi of PX but we which is again
just a Channel of information
again you have this idea that because
you're doing a joint operation the
behavior is linked through the same
parameter which is PX the type of the
input code word and then you can
optimize over PX okay but because you
don't adapt you kind of you hit that
minimum here you have a compound
capacity constraint
okay so we can characterize that exactly
what's nice is when you have something
like that you can ask yourself what are
good channels for which you don't have a
trade-off like other channels for which
I get the best of both worlds I you know
it's as if I could maximize for rate and
maximize for the exponent and you get an
abstract characterization but it means
your favorite additive noise Channel
satisfies that so maybe practical
channels actually don't really suffer
from a trade-off that's kind of a
message
again here we have no feedback so when
we talk about feedback
um so we did several things you can try
to close the loop and when you close the
loop what it means is that suddenly the
encoder can learn the state if you learn
the state you can go a little bit beyond
the compound capacity now you can be
limited by the worst case capacity which
is a bit higher because it allows you to
adapt your type of codeword to the state
that you think is the correct one okay
so that's one gain we should expect but
we wanted to think a little bit further
and try to derive inside that are
meaningful for for engineers okay so
that was kind of really the motivation
for us looking at these problems trying
to convince people that hey it's coming
from statistics it's very abstract it's
actually relevant for the problems you
design
and so we decided to cheat a little bit
by allowing
um not just a fixed block lens
transmission but a kind of a sequential
setting like you imagine you have a
stream of data and you can packetize
them okay and you want to see like long
term you know on average you're gonna
transmit over no more than and channel
users but it's on average because you
can do things sequentially and kind of
sometimes you know
that's a little bit longer and maybe
that's fine but we wanted to bring you
this ability of doing closing the loop
and using a sequential detection
strategies
but if you think about what we're trying
to do remember once you start saying you
need to adapt
you have this trade-off that you have to
manage you want to be reliable and you
want to detect well but to be reliable
if your information theories you know
it's not just writing a mutual
information you need to code
right and when you code while you code
you can't adapt and so you have this
tension between the time scales over
which you need to code for reliability
during which you can adapt and then you
can adapt on top of the packets
and so the the key message that we have
here is that when you have a fixed
Channel stage here and we believe that
extends you know under some mild
qualifications to a slowly varying
Channel State these two things can be
compatible like as long as your channel
State doesn't vary too too long you have
enough time to code for reliability and
then you do an adaptation at that time
at the packet level okay
so
um let me
get close to lunch so I'm going to skip
the details so if you want to formulate
exactly what it means to be able to sub
packetize and be sequential two minutes
um you need to be very formal so I'm
happy to talk about that offline but let
me show you the result okay so the
result is that if you do that then you
get a much better a much better
trade-off so the there are two sort of
trade-offs that kick it first
Improvement in the trade-off is that the
moment you're sequential you're not
limited by the return of information
anymore you're limited by the relative
entropy the worst case relative entropy
between two possible States but in
general that's higher than the chain of
information so you get to boost there
second boost is if you close the loop
you're going to be limited by the worst
case capacity Which is higher than the
compound capacity so to see that it's
the worst case capacity of the compound
you need to decipher our expression a
little bit there's still a worst case
we're looking at the intersection over
all possible States but when we take the
union we don't take just the union over
one possible codeword type that we could
transmit because now we can adapt the
codeword type to the state that we
perceive so we take a union over all
possible types that are function of data
is you don't have a single you know code
book that you have to use all the time
you can have as many code books as you
have tetas and so that region is usually
way bigger than the open loop
um you know which didn't have adaptation
it didn't have sequentiality and this is
just Illustrated here in a
artificial example that shows you that
the trade-off you get with the open loop
non-sequential is dwarfed by the you
know open loop uh the closed loop
sequential
but again so the key thing that I want
to convey is this takeaway that I think
is Meaningful for people who design this
communication system is that
you should not try to adapt too fast the
most of the time there's not going to be
the need for that and you can you will
not really lose anything if you sub
packetize your data that gives you this
unit of reliability and you adapt the
parameters of the code that you're using
for reliability as a function of that
feedback to improve your estimation
okay so pictorially we divide our big
transmission into small chunks in every
small check we need a small header
because you need to the receiver to know
what you're adapting so you have to play
these tricks but the proof is extremely
intuitive it's what any engineer would
do I have a little packet send some
information as to what rate you're
setting what do you think the channel is
and and then adapt that at the
transmitter and keep that group going
and it turns out that that's enough to
give you the kind of very nice trade-off
that you obtain here that gives you so
that's kind of our main message is that
forget about these ID models which are
very nice because they're connected to
Red Distortion Theory but unless you
have you know
super Speedy pedestrian running next to
you probably not so relevant but then
you have something slower that you're
trying to estimate
it gives you the ability to code and you
could be very fast so you get
reliability and do a slow adaptation
loop on top of that and that seems to
work as good as if you you could adapt
you know at the simple level
stop here thank you very much
[Applause]